so back in 2015 a couple of Forbes
reporters were walking around Trump
Tower with Donald Trump and we were
going through all of the numbers for the
Forbes 400 trying to figure out how rich
he is this is an exercise that Donald
Trump is embraced over the years and so
he was going through everything with us
and saying you know this is worth this
much this is worth that much of course
most of the numbers were impossibly high
and didn't make any sense one of the
numbers that he said was he said you
know I just got a check for about a
hundred and twenty five million dollars
connected to a skyscraper in New York
called 1290 Avenue of the Americas we
just wait every month and you know here
you've got these two big boring office
buildings don't have trump's name on
them
he doesn't have majority stake in them
and people are saying you know let's
look at Trump Tower let's look at
mar-a-lago let's look at all the things
that are in the news town and here we've
got these two assets that no one's
talking about that happened to be the
most valuable assets in his entire
portfolio and not only are they valuable
now but they've kicked off an enormous
amount of cash in the past it don't even
knew about at first honestly we thought
that it wasn't true we thought that
there was no way that he could have
gotten so much money out of one building
particularly kind of a nondescript
building that most people don't think
about but then we did some more
reporting and we ultimately concluded
that we did believe that he was telling
the truth
people have speculated a lot about where
Donald Trump's cash is coming from and a
lot of questions about whether it's from
Russia or secret lenders and it seems
that we've stumbled into you know one
big portion of it really might be as
simple and straightforward as a
nondescript office tower in Manhattan
that doesn't even have Trump's name on
it and is run by a publicly traded
company whose CEO is just a quiet
billionaire you know you just even the
people who work inside these buildings
some of them
don't even know that they're paying
money in part to the president yeah yeah
and the tenants you know I mean I asked
the tenants last year okay you know what
do you have to say about the fact that
you're paying $100,000 $200,000 whatever
to the President of the United States
and some of them came back and you know
said well it's a business transaction
whatever but a few of them came back and
said huh what we're paying the president
they didn't even have any idea right I
mean if you say his entire empire takes
in about 175 million in revenue per year
in rent per year and 53 million of it
comes from this one building that
nobody's paying any attention to I mean
that's that's a hell of a story you know
this helps explain one of the big
questions about Donald Trump's fortune
which is where is he getting all of his
cash you know a lot of people have
speculated about different lenders that
he could have or secret funders that he
could have you know here we've found 125
million dollars which is a huge amount
of money for anyone even Donald Trump
that doesn't seem to have been reported
anywhere before
you